JO-EL VAN BERGEN: Welcome
to Google I/O day two,
and thanks for joining us
first thing in the morning.
It's good to see
people out here.
As you can see, we're talking
about the Drive login velocity
across your platforms with
the Google+ Sign-In product.
My name is Jo-el van Bergen,
and this is Randy Merrill.
And we're both software
engineers on the Platform team.
We actually work on
parts of these products.
So let's get started.
OK, so today we're here to
talk about Google Sign-In.
And there's three
things we'd like
you guys to remember by
the end of this talk.
One is that the Google+ Sign-In
product is easy to implement
across your Android,
iOS and web devices.
And we'll show you a bit of
the code in that after a moment
where Randy's going
to actually talk
about the actual
implementation, and we
can go through some
sample code with you guys.
The second is, the Google+
Sign-In product is a truly
cross-platform product.
And we're really committed to
helping you drive conversions
from one platform to another.
As well, we really
want to help you
create a seamless experience
for users across all
of their devices, whatever
they might be using.
And finally, Google+ Sign-In
will help your users bring
their Google identity
with them to your app.
And we found this really reduces
friction on the Sign-In process
and helps users get involved
with your app right away.
As well, we've had
some of our partners
find that Google
signed-in users are
some of the most engaged
users in some of the studies
that they've done.
So I'm going to start by
showing an example of how
the product looks today.
So here we have
the Fancy, which is
an app where you can browse
and view different things
and kind of bookmark, or as
they call it, Fancy things
that you like, and then
later purchase those items.
So here, if the user clicks
the Sign In With Google button,
they get taken to an
authorization screen
where it lets the user know
what the Fancy wants to see.
So it's showing them that they
want to know the basic profile
and that they want
to make the review
activities available to
Google from the Fancy.
And at this point, if the
user had multiple accounts
in their device, they
would get the option
to select one of
their accounts--
and I'm sure many of
you guys on Android
have already seen this--
select one of their accounts
to use with the Fancy before
proceeding to the authorization
screen.
Once the user clicks
Sign In, the Fancy
then shows a username and a
profile picture for that user.
And this is very important.
If you've attended many of
the design talks or the user
experience talks
here, our team will
say that it's great for
showing consistency to the user
so they know what's happened.
They have feedback on
what's actually going on,
and then they also get reminded
of which account they chose.
Especially if they're
coming back to your app
at a later date, they know
which of their Google accounts
they're actually using.
OK, so let's say they've been
using your app for a while,
and then they make their
way to your website.
The Google+ Sign-In product
gives a way to do silent
authentication.
So this means that
if the user's already
signed on one of the
other devices, one
of the other platforms,
when they come
to the new platform--
in this case,
web-- they'll
automatically be signed in
without having to see
another authorization screen,
without having to
type another password.
And this works as long
as they're already
signed in on that device.
So in this case, web, if they're
signed in to any Google product
on their web browser or signed
in to their Chrome browser,
they'll automatically
be signed in.
And then here we have, as
part of the sign-in process,
we show the user name
and the profile picture
again so the user knows
what's actually happened.
All right, so let's take
a look at a new scenario.
Let's say that a user has
come to your website first.
After they've clicked Sign In
on that authorization screen
then we showed you
previously, they're
going to get shown an option
to install your Android
app directly from web through
to their Android phone.
So that they're on
their web browser.
They've clicked Sign In.
They get this pop
up where they can
pick any number of
their Android devices,
whether it's their tablet
or their smartphone.
And as soon as they
click the Install button,
it's automatically
going to start
installing on their phone.
So this means they don't have
to take it out of their pocket.
They don't have to
set a reminder later.
They don't end up forgetting
to install your Android app.
It automatically happens.
And then as soon as it finishes
happening, say a few minutes,
depending on their
internet connection
and how big the app is,
they get a notification
showing them what's
already happened
and giving them a chance
to try your app out
for the first time.
So it just reminds
them, gives them
a way to give it a first try.
OK, so now that we know
what it looks like,
let's take a look at some
of the case studies of what
our partners have found
with using Google+ Sign-In.
Hotel Tonight is a
hotel booking service.
They found that they had 100%
increase in their Android
signed-in user base after
implementing Google+ Sign-In.
As well, they found that Google+
signed-in users were 50% more
likely to purchase than users
signed in with other products.
And finally, they found that
Android user base grew 50%
after implementing
Google+ Sign-In.
So they had a 50% growth in
just Android overall users
after implementing
the Sign-In product.
Which, yeah, we were very
happy with those findings.
Deezer is a music
streaming service.
Deezer found that 33%
of the Google users
who came to their website
chose to install their Android
app immediately via
that over-the-air
install that I just showed you.
They found that
Google users were
two times more likely to
purchase upgraded accounts.
And they found that
Google users listened
to 15% more music than those
using other sign-in methods.
OK, so now we're
going to get into some
of the code of how you can
actually implement this,
and I'll let Randy
talk to you about that.
RANDY MERRILL: So we've
seen the experience
that people get when they
actually use the product.
Huh?
JO-EL VAN BERGEN: Closer.
RANDY MERRILL: Closer.
OK.
I'll talk louder.
OK, so now we're going
to get into the code.
But before we do,
we're actually going
to go to the Google
Developer Console.
So you'll need to go to
the Developer Console
first before you
start programming.
You'll register your app, and
you'll create a project for it,
and you'll get back a client ID.
That client ID is
what you'll use
in actually talking
to the Google APIs.
So we're going to
go to Android now.
In your app, you will use the
Google Play Client Library,
which we provide for you, which
actually connects to the Google
Play Services APK that is
running on phones Gingerbread
and later.
That's something that we provide
that's automatically updated.
And then we help you basically
talk to Google's APIs
through the Google Play client
library and the Google Play
Services APK.
So now I'm going to show you
an example of using the code.
In our onCreate method,
we will actually
create a Google
API Client Builder.
We're going to
add our callbacks,
and we're going to select
which API we're going to use.
In this case, we're going
to use the Google+ API.
And then we're also
going to add a scope.
Here we're using the
Google+ Login scope.
We'll talk more about what
the scopes mean later.
So we build that.
And then on the
start, we connect
to the Google Play Services APK.
And then likewise on stop, we
disconnect from the Google Play
Services APK.
And then in your
app, in your UI,
you just add to your
XML layout, you'll
add the Sign In button
where you want it to appear.
And that's most of it.
And in iOS, we provide
a iOS SDK that you
can use in your app,
which then helps
you talk to the Google APIs.
So here's an example
of the code to do that.
We use the GPP sign-in,
shared instance.
You set some attributes on it.
We set the client ID, which we
got from the Google Developers
Console earlier.
We set that we want to also get
the Google email address back
as part of the request.
And we also set the scopes.
Here again, we're using
the plus.login scope.
And then we set the
delegate to the self.
And then we trigger the
actual authenticate method.
You'll also notice that we
try the silent authentication,
which Jo-el was talking about
earlier, of being able to sign
in users who have signed
in previously on the web
or on Android.
It'll automatically sign them
in if they've already done so.
On the web, you
use the plusone.js
to talk to Google
APIs, make it easier.
You place the plusone.js
before the closing body tag.
And then you put in
the G+ Sign-In button.
Here, with the
data attributes, we
are setting that we want
the plus.login scope again.
We're also using
the client ID which
we got from the Google
Developer Console earlier.
And we're also
setting a callback.
In our callback, we get
presented with an authResult.
And then in that
authResult we check
to see if they have
an access token.
If that access token
is there, then we
know that the user was
signed in successfully.
If that isn't there, then we
can check the authResult error
to see what the problem was
or why the sign-in failed.
And now Jo-el will
talk to us about how
we can move onto
the server as well.
JO-EL VAN BERGEN:
OK, so we've talked
about how to implement this
on the client-side code.
If you want to do asynchronous
calls from your server
to Google APIs-- and this can
done even if the user does not
have the client app open.
So here, at the
top of the screen,
we kind of talked about the
client-side flow where your app
has integrated Google+ Sign In.
When the user clicks
on the Sign In button,
there's going to be
an OAuth request sent
to Google servers, which then
triggers the Sign-In dialogue
that we were talking about.
And then finally, once
the user has accepted,
there's an access
token returned that you
can use to then make requests
to the Google API calls
from your Android client
or your web client.
If you need to make server-side
calls asynchronously
of whether the user
actually has your app open,
we have an extra thing that
you can add to the flow
where you get a one-time code
returned to your client, which
can be sent to the server.
And then on your server,
you use that one-time code
to communicate with
Google and exchange it
for a separate access
token and a refresh token
that your server can use
to make calls on its own.
And the access tokens will
expire after about an hour,
but the refresh token can
be used to get a new access
token at the time
that you need it.
And this is handled
automatically by, I guess,
the server-side client
libraries that Google provides
for various languages
for the sign-in product.
OK, so let's look
at how to implement
this for a web example.
Here in the Sign
In button, you're
going to add two new lines.
One is the data redirect URI,
which you set to postMessage.
And the second is
the data access type,
which you set to offline.
And this just enables
the one-time code flow
that's going to allow
you to send that token up
to your server.
In JavaScript,
you're going to need
to handle the sign in
callback with the auth result.
And in this case,
we actually want
to check the auth
result of code is set.
And that's going to
be that one-time code
that I was referencing.
Once you have the auth result
of code, you can use that.
Here we're using jQuery
to send a postMessage up
to a PHP server in this
case where we set the data
parameter to that code
that we got from Google.
Looking at the server-side
code, here we're in PHP,
and we're assuming that we have
that server-side PHP client
library for Google+
Sign in installed,
and that's where the client
variable is coming from.
So here we're going to make
a call to Google servers
where we take the request value
that you got from your client
app with the Get-Content,
which is going
to be that code that you sent.
And we're going to send that to
the client.authenticate method,
which is what actually makes
the request to the Google OAuth
servers to get your
new access token
and your new refresh
token for the server.
Once you get the
access token back,
you can decode it
from the response,
and there's a verification step.
Now, the verification
step is a bit lengthy,
so we didn't want to
include it on the slides.
But this is a good
time for me to mention
that there's great documentation
on developers.google.com that
includes various languages.
So if you're using
Python, or PHP,
or whatever language
works for you,
we have sample code for all
of these different languages.
And it's just a
really great place
to see more detailed
documentation.
There's a lot more
commenting in the code
there because there's
obviously the room for it.
And a lot of the explanations
we're talking about here
are also explained in
the code as well as
in the accompanying
documentation,
so be sure to check that out.
And then finally, the last
step we're showing here
is it's important to save
that token, obviously,
in whatever way makes
sense for your app.
So in this case, we're saving
in the session variable,
but however you
plan to-- I guess
in whatever way it
makes sense for your app
to use the token
later on, you want
to make sure you have it around
to make future calls on behalf
of that user.
And then finally, it's good to
let your app know that this has
succeeded so that your app knows
it doesn't have to retry this
at a later date.
All right.
So the next thing I want
to talk to guys about
was incremental authorization.
So this is the
principle that you only
want to ask for permissions
that you absolutely
need when your user
first signs in,
and only ask for the permissions
you need it when you need them.
So the main benefit
of this is it really
reduces the friction and the
barrier of entry into your app,
and it keeps the user's
life a lot more simple.
So they see a sign-in.
You only asked for
a couple of things.
It means the user is going
to be a lot more likely just
to click Sign In,
and they're not
confused by why you're asking
for what you're asking for.
And then at a later
time, when you really
need some new scope
or some new ability
or some new information
from Google,
you can ask for those
scopes at that time.
So as part of the
Google+ Sign-In product,
we provide a way for
you guys to do this.
So here, let's say you had
gone to the 8tracks website.
So 8tracks is a music
streaming service.
You choose to click
Sign In With Google+.
And here the consent
is fairly basic.
It's asking to know
your basic profile info.
It's asking to make your listen
activities available to Google.
And it's asking to view
your email address.
So this is pretty standard
nowadays with social sign-in.
Once the user signs
in, they have a chance
to browse around your website,
in this case listen to music,
favorite some things,
take a look around.
And then on the side,
there's a little option here
to mix in recommendations based
on your YouTube watch history.
And it gives the user the
option to click the button
to connect the YouTube account.
In this case, once
they click that button,
they're going to be shown a new
authorization screen which only
asks for the scopes that
are new, so in this case
the YouTube scope.
We're not re-showing
them the whole list.
We're not given them a
giant list to look through.
And it makes sense, because the
user has performed an action
to cause this to happen.
They know that they want to
connect their YouTube account,
so when Google says 8tracks is
asking for a YouTube account,
it really makes sense.
All right.
So let's take a look at how
we can get this implemented.
We've shown you the code, the
basic login flow on Android.
To add a new scope
after the user has
been using your app
for a while, you're
going to need to disconnect
your previous Google API client.
And then you end up connecting
a new Google API client
with an expanded set of
scopes, so whatever new scope
or new piece of
information that you want.
This is going to fail initially,
because that scope has not
been granted to your app yet.
The user has not given
permission for it.
So you're going
to have to handle
the onConnectionFailed
callback on Android
by showing a new dialogue,
and this dialogue
will contain that new scope that
I just showed you previously.
On iOS it's very similar.
You're going to
append the new scope
to the GPP sign-in instance.
Then you call the authenticate
method, similar to the Android
example, and again handle the
finishedWithError callback
by showing the
dialogue to the user
so that they can
accept the new scope.
On web, it's more of
a one-step process.
All you need to do is
request the additional scopes
with the
gapi.auth.signin method.
OK, so Randy, now that we know
how to implement the APIs,
he's going to talk to you
about what you can actually
do with them.
RANDY MERRILL: So in
our earlier examples,
we actually used the
Google+ login scope,
but I'm going to show you some
of the other scopes that you
can use and what
they get for you.
So we're going to start
off with the profile scope.
The profile scope is almost
the basic login scope.
It gives you the
basic information
about the Google user.
It also gives you
a "me" pointer,
which I'll talk about later when
we show an example of using it.
And then we also get the
ability to do over-the-air
install for Android apps.
Then we have the Google+
login, which we demoed earlier,
which actually includes
everything that the profile
does, plus it gives you the
Google+ user's age range
and their language.
Additionally, it gets you the
list of users in the Google+
circles who the user has
specified that you can see
and also allows you to write app
activities such as 8tracks did
with listening activities.
And then we also have an
OpenID Connect profile
that you can get
from the scopes.
We also have an
email scope which
gets you the Google
user's email account.
And if they are Google
Apps for Business user,
it also gets you
the domain name back
so you can verify that
they belong to that domain.
We also have a
plus.profile.emails.read,
which gets you
everything in the email.
Plus, if the user has
any additional emails
in the Google+ profile
that are verified,
it will also return
those to you.
So here we're going
to show some examples
of using the different scopes.
This is a REST
example, but we also
have APIs built into the
web, iOS, and Android
that make this a
lot easier to do.
So here we're doing a GET
request to the Google APIs.
You'll notice on the end we're
doing userID in brackets.
The "me" pointer that I
was talking about earlier
makes it so that instead of
putting in the actual user ID,
you can use the
currently-authenticated user
and use the "me" token
in the place of that.
So this will get you their
basic profile information.
This is how to get the OpenID
Connect profile for the user.
We also have the
more social ones
where you can get the people
that are visible to your app,
those circles that
the user selected.
And also, there
is a connected API
that you can use to get the
ones that are also connected
to your app that are
in their circles.
So to recap, you can actually
use Google+ Sign In with any
Google account.
That includes Android users,
Gmail users, YouTube users,
and Google+ users.
All of those users can actually
sign in using Google+ Sign In.
We talked about providing
a very seamless experience.
The way that you do
that is for asking
for permissions in context.
You don't want to ask
for 20 permissions
at the first of your app
when they don't make sense
to the user.
You want to actually provide
them the minimum at the first,
and then add on
as they need them
and as they are actually
using the features that
require those.
Then we also have the Auto
Sign In on app start up.
So if you've already
used it on the web
and you go to the Android, it's
going to automatically sign you
in with the same permissions.
We also want you to show on your
app the user's name and photo
so that they can
actually see what
account they've signed into,
and it makes sense to them,
and it reminds them
of what's happened.
We also allow you to do
over-the-air installs
for Android from signing
in on the web, which
makes a very good for
converting users from the web
over to your mobile device.
From here, you can go on to the
Google+ Sign In documentation
page.
Go to
developers.google.com/plus.
You can find examples in iOS,
Android, and the web there,
and we have further
documentation
on all the different pieces of
this, as well as code examples.
So thank you.
And if you have any
questions, I think
we still have a
couple of minutes.
JO-EL VAN BERGEN: And if you
guys have questions afterwards,
we'll be sitting around.
So feel free to come
up and talk to us.
Thank you.